I'm planning a trip to this place
called Soul City.
It's a town here at the edge of
North Carolina
that exists on Google Maps but is missing
on many others.
Back in the 70s...
this was an ambitious and
experimental town...
built and led by Black Americans.
A utopia on thousands of acres
of former plantation land...
that would help them gain social
and economic power.
It was the dream of one man:
Civil rights activist Floyd McKissick...
who for a time found
an unexpected ally:
Republican President Richard Nixon.
A lot of the town got built.
A clinic and an industrial park.
People started moving in.
But the reason you don't see it
on most maps today...
is because it doesn't exist
like it was supposed to.
If you ride around today, you're going to see
empty buildings...
vacant buildings...
particularly that at one time
they weren't vacant.
We were rising.
We rose up.
We're just getting there.
We were just becoming viable.
That's when the rug got pulled from underneath us.
So whatever happened to Soul City?
Floyd B. McKissick was a prolific
civil rights activist.
By the 1960s, he was the first Black law student
at the University of North Carolina.
He was an attorney defending activists
arrested at protests.
He led one of the most pivotal civil rights
organizations in the US.
And he was also one of the organizers
of the iconic 1963 March on Washington.
Here he is next to
Martin Luther King.
But McKissick believed progress
for Black Americans
had been slow and inadequate.
So for years, he set his sights on
one big idea.
What if there was an integrated town.
Where everyone...
especially racial minorities and
the poor can thrive.
A planned community
where Black Americans can chart
a new path towards equality.
He called it Soul City.
He was a soldier in World War II
and he'd seen cities getting rebuilt...
over in Europe.
After they were completely destroyed
and demolished.
And he was intrigued and fascinated
by the way
you could rebuild cities and
rebuild communities.
That's McKissick’s son.
I'm Floyd B. McKissick Jr.
He's a former North Carolina senator
and attorney.
And was director of planning on
the Soul City Project.
Oh, I was extremely optimistic.
I mean, I felt this whole city...
represented new hope,
new opportunity...
something that could epitomize
the American dream.
I mean, we lost King.
We lost Kennedy.
We lost another Kennedy.
We lost Malcolm X.
There were so many things happening around us
that there was a reason to say:
Let's build ourselves an economy
and live our lives another way.
That's Jane Ball-Groom,
a native New Yorker
who started working with McKissick
in the late 1960s.
Back when his company
McKissick Enterprises
focused on bringing new Black-owned
businesses to Harlem.
Are you in this photo?
This is me.
It was a time of hope.
The hope was that you could do
anything you wanted to do.
Unlike groups like the Black Panther Party
which embraced distinctly socialist values
“All power to the people.”
McKissick embraced the idea
of Black capitalism...
to make his vision of Black power...
a reality.
That if capitalism existed
in our country...
that African-Americans need to be part
of that economic mainstream.
They deserved an opportunity
to share in building their communities.
How do you get money?
We're not born with it.
We can build own businesses.
McKissick’s plan was for Soul City
to foster industry
where the money would flow
from businesses to the community.
He also had expansive ideas of what
the community would offer
like sports facilities, a pool,
parks, a daycare...
residential villages built beside churches,
bike paths...
a shopping area, housing for
senior citizens.
A health clinic known as Health Co Inc
and Soultech 1:
A huge 73,000 square foot building
designed to be an incubator
for new industry that could bring
24,000 jobs.
Your job would be no more than
10 minutes from your home.
This would be a place where
people of all ages
races and religions
worked together.
A city without prejudice,
without poverty.
A brand new shining city.
By the year 2000
they projected
50,000 residents.
But in order to build this
new town from scratch
one that people and businesses
would want to move to...
McKissick needed funding and
political support.
Luckily, by the late 1960s
the US government was interested
in moving people out
of densely populated areas
and into new towns
with economic opportunities.
In 1968, they launched a program
under the Department of Housing
and Urban Development or HUD
which would offer financial assistance
to a select few proposals for new towns
across the country.
McKissick saw it as an opportunity
to finally make Soul City happen.
But to get access, he'd still need
political allies.
In 1968, he first pitched his idea
to President Lyndon Johnson
but Johnson soon decided not to
run for reelection.
So McKissick took his idea
to the new leading
Democratic candidate for president,
Robert F Kennedy.
Kennedy supported the project...
but in June of 1968,
he was assassinated.
McKissick then made
a calculated decision...
one that was incredibly rare
and controversial for Black activists
at the time.
He looked to Republican candidate
Richard Nixon...
who was favored to win the next election
and hoped that he would
support his project.
It's about survival.
And sometimes you have to learn
how to play the game.
Later, that year, Nixon won the election.
And then did something surprising.
He actually supported McKissick’s dream
of an anti-racist town.
But why?
The Republican Party looked
a lot different back then.
It was focused on appealing to the broadest
possible number of voters.
It's why we see Nixon's deeply conservative policies,
including the start to the devastating
war on drugs...
alongside brief moments of liberal policies.
“We have passed new laws
to protect the environment.”
“Tonight, I therefore propose
a new family assistance.”
I am also proposing a major expansion
of daycare centers.
It wasn't because Nixon necessarily
cared about these policies.
It was just part of the plan
to diversify his base.
And that meant seeking out
Black activists too.
One of the things that President Nixon
supported and was intrigued by...
was this idea of Black capitalism and
Black entrepreneurship.
Soul City fit in neatly within that umbrella.
In 1969, McKissick Enterprises
publicly announced plans for Soul City.
“The former head of Core, Floyd McKissick...
offered an idea today for creation
of a black built
black owned town.
“In this new town persons will be able to control
their own destinies...
McKissick said he anticipates federal aid
in planning and developing the town.”
In 1971, Soul City submitted a proposal
to HUD for funding.
Around that time, McKissick
officially switched
to the Republican Party
and became one of the most prominent
Black civil rights activists
supporting Nixon's reelection.
And by July 1972...
his alliance with Nixon paid off.
Soul City was chosen as 1 of only 13 proposals
for HUD's New Towns program.
McKissick Enterprises would receive
$14 million in federal funding.
It was the first development company led
by Black Americans
to create a new city with government funding.
That didn't go down well with everyone.
Soul City had critics.
One of them was a newly elected North Carolina
senator named Jesse Helms...
a deeply conservative Republican...
and a segregationist with a
long record against civil rights.
He was opposed to Soul City
being a part of the state from the start.
He couldn't get in the way of federal support
for the project.
But he'll come up later in this story.
McKissick chose here in rural
Warren County, North Carolina
to build it.
It was thousands of acres of
former plantation land
with almost no existing infrastructure.
But reclaiming this space was important.
Its history was significant.
A community that represented the future
and a land that represented the worst of our past.
An old former plantation built by slaves.
We were coming out of what was so dark
into that light of this—
is possible for us.
And now we can be somebody
in this country.
Warren County was also one of many areas
in the American South
that had experienced waves of outward migration
over the past several decades.
Black people moving from rural
to urban areas in search of jobs.
But Soul City was designed to create
a reverse migration...
moving people back to the South.
He said we need to change the face
of the rural South.
You need the staff to go south.
I said, I’ll go, so I talked
to my husband.
And I said, well, I'll go
for two weeks.
Jane was one of the first people
to move here...
and she never left.
Been in Soul City since January 1970.
We had young engineers
just getting out of college.
Architects from all over England...
Africa, certain places in the United States.
Soul City was at that time,
literally, a university,
on how to grow a town.
We were all students.
By 1973, McKissick Enterprises
finally broke ground.
Finally, construction.
This was what became the Soul City Boulevard.
We took raw land
that did not have water and sewer,
did not have roads
and we had to really build
an infrastructure.
Our first major project was
a regional water system...
that not only provided water
to Soul City...
but provided water to a region.
It was the largest regional water system
built in the state of North Carolina
at that time.
It continues to operate and function to this day.
Being around people who were involved
with building was transformative.
Everything was a clay dirt road.
Seeing a tractor trailer coming down
on a Monday morning
hearing buzz saws and smelling paint
and seeing old roads transferred
into cement roads like paved
driveways was simply amazing.
So you became taller — I’m five feet.
But those days, I was 5’7”.
I knew I was somebody. To be
young, gifted and Black.
I was raised as a Negro child
in Mt. Vernon New York.
But to be a whole new persona:
You become something else.
They also built out electric.
A fire department, a park,
and recreational facilities.
They built out the health clinic...
along with the massive Soultech 1
industrial park...
which would become the new home
of all of McKissick planning operations, too.
And they built the first of three
planned residential villages
where Jane lives to this day.
But by the late 1970s, Soul City
still have less than 200 residents
even though they'd projected thousands by then.
And they had no real commitments
from big businesses to move here.
Even though McKissick was trying to court companies
like General Motors.
McKissick had a vision, a team, and infrastructure.
So where were the people?
“1973 dramatized US dependence
on foreign oil.”
“We're in an energy crisis now.”
“We have at present an absolute shortage
of natural gas.”
In the 1970s, industries were hesitant
to move or invest in new areas.
This was a problem.
Soul City was the only new town
that was trying to build in a rural place
that was truly freestanding.
The other projects were coming up next to bigger
urban areas that could provide jobs.
There was also the question of its name.
Even though Soul City repeatedly
branded itself as a multiracial community.
Some believed it invoked the idea
of an all black town.
If there was a city that was, say, 70% white.
And about 30% Black
people would think of that as a
racially integrated community.
In Soul City's case, it would have been 70% black...
and 30% white or of mixed races.
People would have thought of that
as an all-Black town.
Then there was Jesse Helms
and his attacks on Soul City.
When have you ever heard of a senator
fighting to stop the flow of funds...
into their states or into their districts...
it's contrary to everything that one
would logically think about?
Those are the types of projects
you would embrace.
But Jesse Helms was a,
to be candid
a segregationist who never repudiated his views.
His final attack came in 1975...
when the country was still reeling
from the aftermath of Watergate.
“Five people have been arrested
and charged with breaking into the headquarters
of the Democratic National Committee.”
“The biggest White House scandal
in a century.”
“The Watergate scandal broke wide open today.”
“I shall resign the presidency effective
at noon tomorrow.”
Helms capitalized on the scandal
and the fact that McKissick and Soul City
were tied to Nixon.
He accused Soul City of various
financial wrongdoings...
repeatedly calling it a waste
and a boondoggle.
And Helms, along with another
North Carolina congressman
demanded a federal audit on the project.
That investigation froze HUD funds
and progress for over a year.
They had kind of a chilling impact
on Soul City's reputation.
The Raleigh News and Observer
wrote a series of articles
on alleged mismanagement of funds at Soul City.
They ran editorials, including
cartoons of McKissick...
that slowly destroyed public opinion.
They could not conceive
of an African American development company
going out there
and having the expertise and capacity
to build a new town.
They thought it was fraud.
They thought there was abuse
and all types of allegations were made.
By December 1975
A government audit cleared Soul City
of any major wrongdoing,
but it was too late.
I went to lunch one day.
I was coming back into Soultech 1,
into the parking lot
and one of the workers stopped me, says Jane,
it’s over.
I said what do you mean it’s over?
He said they've shut the project down.
The bad press had scared people
and big business away.
And in 1979, HUD pulled the plug.
It would no longer fund a Soul city.
“Today, the Department of Housing
and Urban Development...
said it's cutting its ties to Soul City, North Carolina.”
“There have been hopes that industry would come here.”
“That never happened.”
“That's why the government concluded
the project would never make money.”
“I think racial prejudice is
what makes people say we have failed.”
“I said what are we gonna do?”
“I'm too old to move in a place else.”
“You know and I wouldn't like to move.”
“We live at home.”
“Without federal money
and without industry here...
This town will not survive.”
McKissick couldn't fund the project on his own.
He had to foreclose and sell off most of the land.
Today, you can still see a few remnants of what once was.
There's the church and the old
Health Co building.
The clinic operated in the community
for decades after Soul City shut down.
But it's been closed for years and is now abandoned
and overgrown with plants.
And then there’s Soultech 1.
Today, it's been taken over
by a new industry.
A prison work complex.
It does not symbolically incorporate
what my father would have thought of as providing...
a second chance for people.
Soul City represented a second chance.
The remains of Soul City are a testament to what
they were able to accomplish with
little funding and short time.
Within a seven year period of time
we built the roads, the houses, complexes...
from nothing came... a lot.
We rose up.
Red clay to what you see today.
The park pool and sports facility
still serve the community
as well as the roads and water infrastructure.
Many of the homes along cul de sacs remain,
though just a handful of the original Soul City
residents still live there.
I didn't want to go back.
I said, I'm not going anywhere.
I'm staying right here.
Floyd McKissick also never gave up on this place.
He lived here until his passing in 1991...
and was laid to rest in Soul City
near the home
he and his family built.
Though his dream was cut short
to his family and friends...
this will always be a place
that embodies possibility...
not failure.
That's what Soul City is.
It's about hope.
It's about dreams.
Did it become the reality that we envisioned?
The answer is no.
But can we learn from that?
And can we think about what that symbolizes
in terms of moving forward in America?
The answer is absolutely yes.
Thanks for watching.
I'm Ranjani, the producer
of this episode.
So one of the interesting things
I learned while researching this history
is that Warren County
where Soul City is also, made national news
again in 1982
as the birthplace of the environmental
justice movement.
It's where Black residents led an iconic protest...
against the state's plan
to place a toxic landfill in their community
and sparked a national movement
against environmental racism
that's still going today.
Floyd McKissick was one of hundreds
of protesters arrested.
I'll put a few links about that history
in the description below, if you're interested.
And before you go, I have a request.
We pick stories like this for Missing Chapter
to help as many people as possible
have access to hidden history
without a paywall
to help keep our journalism free and
support more of our work.
You can go to vox.com/give
to make a contribution.
We're gearing up for a big year full of
ambitious projects
and are looking to hit 85,000 total
contributions by the end of 2023.
So if you can contribute at the link below
to help us reach that goal.
Thanks again for watching and supporting.